[Musique]
bonsoir à tous et bienvenue dans ce set
8 sport sur tv 60,18 l'émission ne pas
manquer si vous êtes un passionné de
sport local c'est parti pour le sommaire
football françois mendy vient de signer
son premier contrat professionnel avec
le club de châteauroux
ce jeune footballeur a débuté le
football au club de l'étoile sportive de
tram nous l'aurons en interview dans
cette émission basket coup de projecteur
aujourd'hui sur mike beau congo le
sportif originaire de république
centrafricaine joue aujourd'hui dans le
club de trappes après avoir vécu une
carrière bien remplie entre châlons au
monaco et l'espagne reportage en
quelques instants
gbagbo les cougars de montillot bretons
ne débuteront finalement leur saison en
première division à la mi juin après
plusieurs reports dus à la crise
sanitaire
interview avec le club à suivre
l'actualité sportive c'est maintenant
sur tb 78
[Musique]
mais avant de développer ces titres on
va parler golf seul français présent
cette semaine sur le circuit américain
antoine brothers n'a pas brillé dans
pour sa grande première sur le pi2g tour
le pensionnaire du golf de la boulie à
versailles n'a pas passé le cut avec un
score total de -5 le 70e mondiale a raté
la qualification pour le week-end pour
un seul coup libinois aura l'occasion de
se rattraper rattraper cette semaine il
participera à son premier majeur us
fidji en caroline du sud avant d'aller
début juin sur le mémorial tournament on
continue à parler de golf si antoine
runner n'a pas brillé une autre
pensionnaire du golf de la boulie a
quant elle performer vas-y rana éclat
jeunes le racing mène deux saisons à
droite de l'image a terminé à une belle
deuxième place aux internationaux du
portugal derrière une autre française la
marseillaise l'uci a mad sheer envahira
la ex vice championne de france
benjamine dans 2019 décroche son premier
podium dans une épreuve internationale
de ce calibre
enter en tennis de l'illinois arthur are
in darkness a beaucoup fait parler de
lui la semaine dernière le 124e joueur
mondial 3e français à la reiss a dénoncé
le gel du classement atp mise en place
depuis l'épidémie de kovy de 19
un système qui permet à certains joueurs
qui ne jouent pas de conserver leur
place au classement cette règle a des
conséquences sur le joueur de saint
germain en laye les vimynois de 25 ans a
joué des tournois challenger il ne peut
pas se qualifier sur des plus gros
tournoi malgré ses performances du
moment alors duré une heure 15 h devrait
tout de même participer à roland garros
à partir du 24 mai grâce à une
invitation de la part à des
organisateurs on va maintenant parler un
football l'ancien trappistes françois
mendy aujourd'hui âgé de 21 ans vient de
signer son premier contrat professionnel
il a signé avec le club de châteauroux
qui évolué cette année en ligue 2 livin
on est arrivé au club il ya trois en
provenance de l'étoile sportive de
trappes françois mendy est avec nous via
écran interposé bonsoir mon son alors il
ya également les éducateurs le l'emblème
on va dire du club de l'étoile sportive
de trappes rodrigues et bizi éducateurs
qui étaient avec nous m'ont soit rodrig
% viken bon sens françois
alors tout d'abord premières réactions à
françois suite à cette signature
je me dis que vous êtes très heureux
satisfaction c'est une satisfaction
c'est je suis très heureux d'avoir signé
ce premier contrat professionnel grande
satisfaction aussi au sein du club de
trappes rodrigues
oui tout à fait michael puisque françois
c'est un garçon qu'on est au club depuis
la catégorie q 6 ans donc il a gravi les
échelons du club jusqu'à la fameuse
saison qui a qui a été bar qui a
déclenché ce fameux c'est un parcours
exceptionnel de france soir qui lui a
permis à henry 18 de ne quitter pour
rejoindre la berrichonne de châteauroux
après trois ans de formation à la bonne
nouvelle est tombée avec la signature de
ce fameux contrat pro père desquels
françois courait depuis un moment quand
même à tout le monde en parle au club ou
pas c'est une fierté parce qu'en fait
françois puis se fait partie de cette
fameuse génération 2000 dont on parle
beaucoup à trappes à une génération qui
a très bien travaillé avec eux deux
garçons prometteurs et tout est bas
françois est vraiment la pierre
angulaire bas 2,7 cette année d'argent
en concrétisant son rêve en devenant
footballeur professionnel et en signant
qu'un son premier contrat pro
françois est ce que vous avez eu des
messages de vos anciens coéquipiers à
trappes biens sont bien sûr les messages
de deux personnes qui sont très heureux
pour moi et franchement j'ai reçu des
messages touchants et sa voix ça m'a
vraiment fait plaisir
alors rodrik vous l'avez dire c'est un
garçon du cru et qui a également des
parents trappistes c'est encore une plus
belle histoire peut-être pour le club le
fait qu'il soit 100% trappistes
sincèrement c'est clair que moi depuis
depuis ces derniers jours au gigot
d'histoire de france soir doit faire
date au sein du club quoi parce que
c'est vrai que il a fait preuve de
beaucoup de patience de beaucoup de
travail et je pense que ça c'est des
valeurs qui est que le club lui a
inculqué durant sa formation trappistes
mais qui aujourd'hui va lui servir au
début de sa carrière et en espérant
qu'ils passent de très grand chose
derrière parce que françois que c'est
très bien c'est ce n'est que le début et
c'est surtout pas une finalité
est ce que vous avez l'habitude au sein
du club de trappes de sortir des des
pépites du deux des équipes jeunes
oui ça nous
donc là bas françois qu'il fait partie
des jarres sow 2000 dont conduite est du
côté de châteauroux en 2000 ans de
quelques mois avant le départ de
françois d'ailleurs on avait très
messieurs qu'est la génération dominant
lui qui était parti du côté de l'aj
auxerre
donc là on a un joueur de si vous trompe
pas d'année c'est 2004 qui erwan djiby
qui est du côté d'amiens et puis surtout
ces derniers temps de joueurs profession
de cons en activité qui est passé par le
club
enfin c'est isaac belfodil qui est
toujours du côté de hoffenheim en
allemagne françois alors la saison
dernière vous étiez avec la réserve de
châteauroux en nationale 3 où vous aviez
inscrit 8 buts en 17 matches est-ce que
vous pensez que ça a pesé dans cette
signature
cette bonne saison je pense je pense
parce que le championnat de la nationale
grâce à un championnat difficile et le
fait que j'aie marqué huit buts dans ce
championnat qui est assez difficile je
pense que ça a pesé dans ce contrat
alors vous avez joué également
cette saison plusieurs matchs de ligue2
marco simonet vous a lancé dans le grand
bain si on peut dire même si c'était
seulement quelques minutes
est ce que ça vous a permis de goûter à
ce haut niveau et qu'est ce que vous en
avez pensé
j'en ai pensé que d'abord tout d'abord
j'étais un peu stressé un peu mais quand
j'ai mis les pieds sur le terrain bah
franchement j'étais j'étais très heureux
assez concentré mais j'étais très
heureux franchement c'est bien
c'était bien rodrigues que vous avez pu
voir c'est l'essai début du coup en
ligue 2 vous les avez regardés fait et
je vais te d'être avec vous michael en
toute sincérité je ne regarde jamais les
matchs de ligue2 parce que si c'est
généralement des horaires un peu
particulier tout ça mais dès qu'on a
appris que françois était dans le groupe
pour le match contre clermont
vous avouerez que j'ai trouvé le moyen
de t'avoir been pour regarder certains
de match et je vous avouerai que quand
on l'a vu leurs entrées ça nous a fait
vraiment chaud au coeur parce que
françois est un garçon qu'on connaît
très très bien au point sincèrement on
l'a vu grandir tout ça et ils devoir
adapter ccc franchement choquant quoi
mais voilà il nous a donné un bon il n'a
pas beaucoup joué mais c'était quelques
instants de bonheur sans ça alors vous
avez signé pour trois ans avec
châteauroux est ce que c'est une bonne
durée selon vous françois pour
progresser franchement oui parce que ça
va me laisser du temps pour prouver ce
que j'ai approuvé et signé ce temps là
avec mon club formateur franchement je
pense que c'est une bonne chose
alors vous avez 21 ans vous faites un
mètre soixante dix huit pour 69 kg
quelles sont vos qualités en tant
qu'attaquant mes qualités je dirais que
c'est la vitesse et je suis un
provocateur j'aime le dribble et marquer
des buts pour dire que vous avez vu très
rapidement sa vitesse quand vous l'aviez
sur les terrains trappe
en fait pour être honnête avec françois
la problématique qu'il avait qu'en était
il était jeune c'est qu'il ya un souci
de taille donc françois une croissance
très tardive
c'est ce qui l'a un peu empêché de nous
de sortir à bon et sinon après au niveau
du travail de la qualité technique et
son sens de l'attaqué sans là on a vu
tout de suite on avait tout de suite
françois faisait partie des garçons la
génération 2000 comme comme je le disais
sur lesquelles on lisait beaucoup vous
étiez également je crois un jour de
futsal également françois est ce que ça
peut jouer également dans votre
progression au niveau technique
notamment quand même franchement oui oui
c'est vraiment de la technique et femmes
a beaucoup aidés ce mois beaucoup aidé
alors vous avez des modèles donc dans le
football est ce que vous en inspirer
françois j'étais grand mauvais quand
j'aime beaucoup neymar qu'elle bénard
fort
johnson chose des grands modèles après
nuit je m'en inspire mais voilà que
c'est le top
et vous en inspirer comment sur le
terrain j'essaie de reproduire ce qu'ils
reproduisent en match c'est difficile
mais ça avance pas voir au travail
autrement on arrive vers la fin de cette
interview quels sont vos objectifs avec
châteauroux la saison prochaine
l'objectif c'est surtout de jouer avant
tout je rappelle que l'équipe saura en
national l'année prochaine nos objectifs
mais objectif était de jouer un max de
temps de jeu au max et franchement
apporter un plus à cette équipe est de
remonter en ligue 2 et de marquer des
buts
oui quand même chose il faut
dernière question est-ce que vous
reviendrez quand même à trappes pour
voir vos anciens collègues
bien sûr bien sûr trappe seulement
famille c'est chez moi c'est moi ville
merci à tous les deux d'être intervenu
dans cette émission continuera
évidemment à suivre votre carrière
françois mendy on espère que d'autres
pépites sortiront également des équipes
de jeunes de trappes et notamment avec
vous à rodrigues
merci beaucoup entrent en première
chambre quand même pas de cotisations
versées à la redécouverte d'une autre
pépite justement dans ce set 8 sport
emilie boulard 21 ans natif de
rambouillet a connu ces trois premières
sélections sein du quinze de france
féminin lors du tournoi des six nations
2021 quatre ans seulement après avoir
commencé le rugby en club à chilly à
mazarin portrait de cette sportive
revinoise à l'ascension fulgurante un
reportage de nicolas d'ombré
[Musique]
boulard c'était le 3 avril 2021 la
première titularisation en équipe de
france d'emilie bouleurs junte
rugbywoman yvelinoise de 21 ans et une
première sélection face au pays de
galles puis une seconde face aux
irlandaises ses débuts sous le maillot
bleu lors du tournoi des six nations
2021 de très bons souvenirs pour sa
famille du côté de la celle les bordes
aller et là ça part allez allez allez
petit coup de pied du pied droit
quand on l'a vu s'aligner avec ses
copines prendre la position et la
marseillaise
on a eu la chair de poule en tout cas
pour moi et une grosse grosse
fierté de voir un de ses enfants avec le
maillot de l'équipe de france nous a une
grosse fierté de l'avoir d'avoir la ce
niveau là en si peu de temps pour ses
premières sélections emilie boulard a
inscrit deux essais en trois matches à
21 ans emilie boulard vie dans la maison
familiale avec ses frères et soeurs une
famille de sportifs avec mes frères et
soeurs ont des global mantoue sportif
donc faire du sport ensemble mais au
collège et au lycée toujours toujours
faire beaucoup de sport et j'ai toujours
aimé ça escalade à partir du collège
pendant cinq ans du coup en club plus à
la sns je fais pas mal de compétition
j'étais championne de france en 2013 et
ensuite du coup je passe au rugby à
partir de là de la première en unss dans
mon lycée agricole
après la pratique avec l'association
sportive du lycée emilie bull a rejoint
le club de chilly-mazarin en 2017
c'est à ce moment là que sa carrière de
rugbyman commence bâle club de chilly
mazarin
ça représente tout parce que c'est mon
seul club où j'ai joué a déjà en seniors
avec ce club essonnien emilie boulard
joue au niveau élite du rugby féminin
elle s'entraîne trois fois par semaine
apprend très rapidement illustration
parfaite de sa progression fulgurante au
bout d'un an elle intègre l'équipe de
france à 7 développement un marcoussis
des films tournés en première tournée en
australie nouvelle zélande je pars trois
semaines je savais pas faire de seven
j'avais un an et demi d'expérience au
niveau rugby pareil très une expérience
qui m'a vraiment fort j'ai donc j'ai dû
apprendre vraiment très vite et ensuite
mais ça c'est continuer les stages avec
le france développement ensuite les
moins de 20 ans suit le
les jo de la légion universitaire et le
15 elle a gravi les échelons d'une
manière exponentielle qui a un peu
surpris tout le monde et notre avantage
pour le club de chelsea donc
donc voila c'était assez spectaculaire
ses prochains objectifs pour cette jeune
rugbywoman participer à la coupe du
monde de rugby féminin et aux jeux
olympiques de paris en 2024
on va ouvrir maintenant une page
basketball coup de projecteur
aujourd'hui sur mike mot congo le
sportif originaire de la république
centrafricaine joue aujourd'hui au club
de trappes après avoir vécu une carrière
bien remplie entre châlons au monaco et
l'espagne avantage d'arthur huyghe dans
sa maison yvelinoise dans la petite
ville dont deux lui mickaël mokongo 35
ans se remémore les plus grands moments
de sa carrière de sportif professionnel
une aventure qu'il a commencé à l'âge de
7 ans dans son pays natal en république
centrafricaine avec un père lui aussi
basketteur c'est vrai que mon papa elle
est partie à barcelone les jeux de
barcelone pas ce qui les faisait partie
de l'équipe qui accompagnait l'équipe
centrafricaine et à son retour une vera
mener un petit panier de basket en
république centrafricaine et c'est là
que j'ai je suis tombé amoureux du
basket et et jusque là j'ai pas quitter
la mickaël mokongo arrive en france à
l'âge de 10 ans et intègre rapidement le
centre de formation de chalon sportifs
débutants professionnelle à l'âge de 17
ans et demi en première division très
vite remarqué le découvre plusieurs pays
comme la turquie chypre ou encore
l'espagne mais c'est avec monaco que le
basketteur connaissait plus belles
émotions de 2013 à 2015 trois belles
années où on a monté le club de national
jusqu'en 1ère division et je garde que
les très bons souvenirs de la ville de
la structure les dirigeants de mes
coéquipiers avec qui on a pu jouer
c'était vraiment une belle expérience
pendant trois ans oui j'ai tourné à peu
près à 15 points de moyenne 15 points et
5 passes de moyenne
donc j'étais assez régulier pendant
pendant toutes ces années là celui que
l'on surnomme affectueusement mike joue
également en équipe nationale après
avoir porté les couleurs de l'équipe de
france ont moins de 18 et moins de 20
ans le basketteur décide d'intégrer
l'équipe de république centrafricaine
le meneur de jeu est devenu le leader de
cette nation pendant une décennie
c'est une fierté pour moi de pouvoir
représenter
mon pays d'origine et franchement j'ai
fait quatre coupes d'afrique
ça c'est vraiment très très bien passé
et je ne regrette pas du tout j'espère
pouvoir faire une dernière coupe
d'afrique encore avec l'équipe
centrafricaine cet été à kigali pour
terminer sa carrière mike a choisi les
yvelines le sportif d'un mètre
quatre-vingt joue dans le club de
trappes en nationale 3 son objectif
guidé l'équipe trappistes en troisième
division
j'aime beaucoup la mentalité j'aime bien
la diversité qui a attrapé et je pense
que la région mérite d'avoir un club à
ce niveau là donc non voilà je prends à
coeur ce projet là pour pouvoir vraiment
les aider
c'est vrai que là locaux vides nous
facilite pas les choses
on espère que l'année prochaine on
pourra bien reprendre la saison mike
mokongo voudrait encore jeu pendant deux
à trois saisons pour aider trappe dans
ses objectifs et surtout transmettre ses
connaissances aux jeunes basketteurs en
parallèle ce fan de kobe bryant va
continuer à mener une carrière de
commentateur sportif pour des chaînes
nationales
toujours en basket le mercato français
risque d'être agitée dans léa prochaines
semaines et en illinois pourrait être
l'un des joueurs les plus demandés son
nom victor webb anyama le sportif de 17
ans passé notamment par le club du
chesnay versailles est aujourd'hui à
nanterre pourrait voir sa carrière monte
d'un cran
il pourrait atterrir à l'asvel l'un des
clubs phares en france le sportif de
deux mètres 19 pourrait arriver cet été
pour une seule saison avant de s'envoler
pour les états unis à l'occasion de la
draft 2022
cette rumeur pourrait se concrétiser
dans les prochaines semaines on continue
par du baseball les cougars de
montigny-le-bretonneux reprendront le
championnat de première division le 13
juin prochain contre l'équipe de rouen
et bonne nouvelle pour le club qui n'a
pas pu jouer en compétition depuis de
longs mois pour nous parler de cette
situation nous avons avec nous via écran
interposé le directeur technique josé
des araujo bonsoir d'enchères michael
alors vous êtes dans quel état d'esprit
avant cette reprise
ben on est un patient en patient de
reprendre me reprendre le championnat et
essayer de retrouver le terrain pour
certains joueurs qui n'ont pas joué
depuis un an
est ce que les joueurs justement
attendait ce rendez-vous avec impatience
est-ce qui vous en parler tout le temps
il on parle tout le temps
ça fait depuis six mois qu'on en parle
qu'on n'arrête pas d'en parler avec la
patience et aussi certaines incertitudes
parce que voilà un qu'on éduque au vide
on n'était pas sûr qu'ils allaient avoir
un championnat parce que l'année
dernière ça a été annulé
donc voilà c'est c'était compliqué pour
eux aussi voilà d'attendre qu'il a on
sait qu'on va reprendre donc le 12 juin
contre euro comme vous l'avez dit alors
vous avez eu peur à un moment que le
championnat ne se déroule pas pour une
deuxième année consécutive où ça soit
une saison blanche pour la deuxième
année consécutive
oui parce que on a eu beaucoup enfin on
a vu autour de mouy les différents que
championnat amateur qui ont été annulés
et le nôtre si c'est un championnat
amateur on n'est pas des professionnels
donc du coup on a vraiment eu peur que
le ministère décide aussi d'animer une
autre on est passé je dirais à travers
et notre championnat va être aussi
bavard reprendront qu'à partir du 12
juin
pour les seniors en national comment ça
s'est passé il ya eu beaucoup de
discussions avec la fédération française
de baseball peut-être la fédération a
beaucoup discuté avec les ministères
pouvoir autoriser cette entreprise
surtout à faire faire valoir la
différence de notre sport par rapport à
d'autres sports comme le foot le basket
etc
donc on a on a on a été quand même
identifié comme sport de contact comme
ça qu'on reprend le 12 et pas avant mais
bon on est quand même contents de
reprendre et de retrouver les terrains
et de pouvoir faire un championnat cette
année
c'était important également de reprendre
pour vos sponsors vos partenaires qui
vous suivent depuis de nombreuses années
oui c'est vrai qu'on a on a la chance
d'avoir
essentiellement je dirais la
municipalité de monique et l'ail qui
nous soutient j'irai tous les ans et il
est surtout à durant cette période qui
était difficile sadique au bide et après
on a des partenaires privés qui sont là
et qui sont là à nos côtés et qui depuis
depuis quelques années il y a et qu'ils
avaient hâte qu'on reprenne
et puis nous aussi d'ailleurs et
d'ailleurs je les remercie pour leur
soutien durant les périodes difficiles
cette nouvelle saison va être
particulière ou
changera finalement pas grand chose par
rapport à un début de saison en avril 1
alors c'est assez particulier parce que
d'une la préparation a été compliquée à
cause justement du coc vide on n'a pas
eu autant d'entraînement qu'on a
d'habitude
donc on a dû faire avec des restrictions
durant la semaine on pouvait pas
s'entraîner nous concentrer n'est que le
dimanche et c'était le dimanche pour
enfin le samedi et dimanche tout le club
donc fallait partager je dirais le
terrain et après certains de nos joueurs
qui ont sondé préparation physique en
salle et c'est que ce n'est pas le faire
non plus puisque les salles étaient
fermés
hélas la reprise de joie telle qu'elle a
été annoncée au fait qu'on a pas
possibilité de faire deux matches
amicaux en préparation ça donc ça va
être assez compliqué de reprendre sa
saison 100 matches amicaux aussi
donc voilà c'est une saison particulière
quand même et après sur la longueur
c'est une saison qui va s'étaler sur
tout jusqu'à septembre alors que
d'habitude on a plutôt un break sur les
deux premières semaines d'août la cette
année on aura pas de vrai que ça va on
va enchaîner
donc voilà on va voir on va faire le
maximum en tout cas on est content de
pouvoir jouer
quels seront les objectifs du club pour
cette saison alors nos objectifs bas
c'est comme vous avez pu enfin comme
vous le savez on est parti en coupe
d'europe il ya deux ans et îlots fictif
a adoré jouer cette drogue donc l'idée
c'est vraiment de repartir donc d'être
déjà dans le carré final du championnat
pour pouvoir aller chercher cette place
en finale et gagner cette finale du
championnat de france qui nous
permettrait de repartir ou où le chaland
que j'ai aussi ce jour en septembre
ou comment l'idée c'est d'être dans les
quatre derniers finalistes pour pouvoir
aller chercher cette récompense pour
l'effectif
dernière question très rapidement qu'est
ce qu'on peut vous souhaiter pour cette
saison 2021
enfin plus de confinement on va dire que
ça que enfin voilà qu'on ait pu qu'on
est petit de cas qui nous fermerait le
terrain et qui qui couperait au fait
dans son élan cette reprise
s'il ya que ça à nous souhaiter merci à
vous josé d'air aux jo on suivra avec
attention la saison 1 des cougars de
montigny-le-bretonneux sur tv soixante
dix huit premiers matches le
13 juin prochain contre rouen à maurepas
au lycée aller à cette mare une
spécialité pratiques et culture sportive
ouvrira ses portes à la rentrée
prochaine dans la structure seulement
trois établissements proposent cette
option dans l'académie de versailles
l'un des professeurs marc lejeune nous
présente ce projet c'est notre interview
express au delà de la pratique sportive
et de l'approfondissement de ces
pratiques sportives
on propose des cours de théorie
notamment pour aborder d'autres champs
disciplinaires comme les sciences
humaines les humanités donc on peut
proposer
bien sûr tout ce qui est relatif à la
physiologie de l'effort tout le lien qui
existe entre la théorie et la pratique
des activités physiques et sportives
c'est destiné à tous les élèves à
l'issue de la seconde qui le souhaitent
il n'est pas nécessaire par exemple
d'avoir suivi l'option au ps en seconde
pour aller et demandé cette cette
spécialité comme ça se comporte comme
tous les autres spécialités en fin de
seconde
c'est à dire que on propose l'élève doit
choisir trois spécialités en première et
on pourrait en terminale il n'en choisit
que deux noms il ans il peut en retirer
une en fin de seconde les tous les
élèves peuvent choisir cette spécialité
parmi les trois qui doit choisir en
première
l'idée c'est de rentrer de toute façon
dans le de pouvoir vivre en quelque
sorte avec cette spécialité aussi bien
en première et en terminale
si l'élève le choisit et bien entendu
dans le cadre de cette réforme on a un
rapport directement avec parcours sup
puisque les élèves qui choisiraient
cette spécialité aurait un attrait
particulier avec tous les métiers qu'ils
aient un rapport avec le corps et donc
on espère que l'algorithme de parcours
sud va pouvoir s'y intégrer au chapitre
des confinement après la levée de la
restriction des 10 km début mai et le
retour du sport scolaire en équipements
intérieurs
ça va s'accélérer à partir de ce 19 mai
il y aura la réouverture des piscines
municipales et le retour du public dans
les stades avec des jauges de 800
personnes en intérieur et 1000 en
extérieur enfin le 9 juin il y aura la
réouverture des salles de sport après
huit mois d'arrêt la reprise du sport
sans contact en intérieur et la reprise
des sports avec du contact en extérieur
la jauge pour les spectateurs sera de
5000 dans les enceintes sportives le
retour à la normale est lui prévu le 30
juin tout cela est évidemment
conditionné à l'évolution de la
situation à sanitaires et on termine par
une information à cyclisme ce mardi 18
mai l'union cycliste internationale va
annoncer une nouvelle compétition
internationale et une membre est une des
manches devraient se dérouler au
vélodrome national de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines le rendez vous
baptisé ligue des champions piste russie
devrait proposer six manches
spectaculaire sur plusieurs sites
pendant six semaines
on y retrouvera les meilleurs
spécialistes de la vitesse et de l
endurance objectif booster les audiences
du cyclisme sur piste
pour l'instant nous n'avons pas la date
officielle pour la manche au vélodrome
national de saint quentin en yvelines
elle devrait se situer en fin d'année
vers le courant novembre
réponse ce mardi c'est la fin de cette
émission merci d'avoir suivi à bientôt
sur tv 78
[Musique]